look at a spoiler corner holy shit that
bulges sodium self-respect what was you
just turn to me this just like put how
did he he was split in half and I just
turned you it was like really cut better
yeah it's either one or two thing cuz
I've waited to the credits I'm just like
wait let me see I said ray park as mall
so okay the I'm his twin brother
yeah it's wrong look either one hell of
an exact doppelganger you know son or
something like that or they're just
gonna be like well he's an alien that
kid kill him he just the image menu
Statham it it country did you initially
see the cat part of him could tell you
still be there he wouldn't that believe
that and he's gonna get robotic legs
adjust what that be amazing
no what about Holly this is you see dark
baldwin's only from stuff he's just on
the floor it's just like god dammit the
other reason I get some floating thing
like Yoda heaven something else I really
liked is that okay so witty Harris so
Hans shoots Woody Harrelson in the
middle of his speeches and Rob goes you
know haha and just all around the
theater every person thought they were
the punch up long jumper and then like
four minutes later my dad leaves over is
like oh yeah but oh yeah gonna literally
the whole pair just like I could just
hear you sitting there seething Rob
thinking
thanks guys notice no I was being
sarcastic cuz like that he shoots him
right after lunch at first because I was
just like blame like it's like you could
tell what they were trying to do with
that like haha like look what we do is
just wait for him to goddamn say but
everybody yeah but but everybody like
after first did you see that God guys
you really fallen for this okay so the
reason that he wants to go back to the
planet is to you know find his
girlfriend and she just shows up he's
told a million I and like literally
right there it's like hi and then they
have a brief conversations and it's just
like oh like she's attached to him like
she's done things now cuz she started
the syndicate I'm like traitor she's
gonna betray oh yeah no like constantly
saying over and over you see playing the
chess game you always got to be a couple
steps ahead of the other hand he's doing
his drunken character from hunger game
this was even would like a bottle of
whiskey and everything yeah so you know
he's gonna be the traitor to and they
keep trying to pull like a red herring
like no she stabbed the other guy
therefore she's not traitor and I'm like
no still traitor and then the sex you
say I'll be right behind you you go
ahead go ahead I'm like traitor like get
on with it get on with a traitor traitor
yeah because what what and that distract
me from the fact that this is really
predictable because I'll say this I
didn't see that one coming only surprise
in the freaking movie um and they did
not yet they even when he sees her it's
just like you know oh you're here cool
so good to see you again like three
years you've been trying you or your
whole life but dedicated to seeing this
person a half yeah okay let's I just
what happened is where were you in
another she's acting cool like that when
she's being taken away I'll come back
I'll come back
it was a big like hey just like so we're
like not what what the hell are you
doing here like in the middle of the
freakin crime syndicate isn't like it's
just like it caught me off guard I'll
give it that but it's like just from
there on it's like well okay then he has
no reason to kind of be doing anything
and then just like every single death is
so cataloged like a thousand pages
before it's gonna have like literally if
you are a pilot in this movie you are a
red shirt on Star Trek like yeah it's
just weari killing everybody off just to
get Han in that fucking pilot see that's
like fucking jon favreau monkey alien
I'm like the second you showed up I'm
like oh I'm the PI I'm like dad yeah and
then the seconds like this is l3 she's
about a navigator copilot I'm like dad
because we know that I think you can't
kill Lando and I'm like dad so it's just
like every single person that like died
in this this is like somehow and the
second what's her face is fawning all
over Beckett's like oh yeah everybody
needs somebody like even an old-time
criminal like you I'm like she's dead
what just ah yeah
so yeah but a lot of people not
surprisingly died in this like okay yeah
woody yeah woody hero sends a girlfriend
or wife or whatever well I did not think
it was a very good um you know when she
goes out and I guess it literally goes
up goes up you know again just just not
a big deal not not a big scene there's
this I guess what's supposed to be a big
reveal where it's like there's these
like you know what oh by the way talking
about that those things were like
freaking probe droids Han and Chewie
took a couple out like in in Empire
could have just turned around the pole
and and fired away I don't know that
that that makes it it makes sense when
freakin Beckett at the end what he I was
like alright big guy you're coming
believe her and like chewy gets in the
elevator with him and the guys guide
Beckett is one blaster and I'm like I
really wanted that elevator they like
the elevator clothes like I wanted the
elevator and open on floor 1 it opens
and there's just Beckett's body on the
ground yeah okay holding his office arms
yeah Chewie does nothing I'm like are
you shitting me your close quarters with
this guy little woody harrelson giant
Chewbacca
just holding his little gun and giant
you fuckin carrying there he looks
ridiculous I remember yeah I'm glad you
said cuz I'm looking at this like she we
could totally grab that gonna kick his
ass and you to bleed overs like this is
kind of embarrassing pushing up ripped
that guy's arms off already you did it
in the castle mines like haha that's
like other references look here's the
dice that Han Solo is gonna hang on his
ship as a reminder that sumbitch
betrayed him what yeah it's like okay so
she's in league with Darth Maul again
just not even like that was don't get
the point that was there or whatever red
herring that almost made me fall for it
cuz I'm just like I'm like there's only
two options second those dice showed up
I'm just like dead I was like traitor
and I was like dead or traitor
and I thought traitor but with those
dice I'm like well maybe she is dead
because that would be Memorial to hang
like the dice there but Emma said now
everything's pointing to traitor and
then she was a traitor which is what I
thought but then it made me wonder why
does he have those dice still then I'd
be like we don't know about the hell she
does they're building it up so much and
they never say I mean I guess that
particle of the mystery but she's not in
trouble they leave a tab a freaking
amazing spider-man 2 this is like the
sinister six shit where it says like
we're building up this
wait to see what every meal I guess and
it's like and there's Darth Maul again
it's like why what and I don't know it's
not something that's like it's not an
intriguing kind of thing it's not like I
really wanna know more cuz nothing else
emotionally made me want to connect with
these now more continue with them um so
uh was the other thing that's like lol
three dies that's a lot of the ship's
computer and like that relationship she
had with Lando it was I don't know what
to make of that so but I'm like damn
Disney you let that happen
yeah like they pretty much have a
conversation where they're all but
saying is like oh yeah she's like oh
yeah you can fuck me I'm programmed to
do that like that's practically what
she's in yeah I'm ready mom I was like
wow like Disney movie okay okay here's
another count weird thing like again
it's I kind of blown it just because
again I mean whoever plays chewbacca the
however they handle Chewbacca in general
I mean it's amazing how much character I
do get out of him but like so he goes
into the mines and there's I guess they
don't even say his tribe his family I
don't know and or you don't know either
but he finds other wookies there and
it's like he's getting out with them and
he's got the group and they're going and
then she we can either go with them or
go over there you know save behind and
everything and maybe really do this cool
little head but again it's like man
chess what head but like it felt like
there's a I thought emotion there more
than anyone else and you know he goes in
to help them house just like so is that
the tribe or the family or what cuz then
he just kind of leads in translating the
wookie so and then Han didn't say
anything that I can remember that told
me who they were
yes but I mean they're they're wiki's so
I guess he felt the need to save them I
get that yeah but no that was any kid
and then that hotline just dropped yeah
so it's like there's a couple things
that kind of build up where it's like
okay I'm down for this like it's it I
felt like a lot of things were being set
up in the opening now I'm like I it
hooked me I'm like okay I want to see
where this goes and then allow them
don't go
don't go anywhere they don't go anywhere
interesting and then I go exactly what
more there is no more like the gambling
scene there was like no setup it's just
like I'm gonna gamble the Oh No
like why oh no we don't know if he's a
good gambler or not he could be how the
fuck do we know and then seems to be
good and then it's just okay like I I
thought that scene was pretty cool so I
can't pay about that yeah I know you're
talking about no no I'd like to see that
soap was good but there was no setup for
it like they needed a they needed a
scene of him gambling earlier to tell us
whether or not he's really good or not
or just something to imply but it's like
it's like there's a joke there that we
weren't let in on cuz everybody has this
reaction like you're gonna do it Yankee
why is this a big deal we don't know if
he's good at this or not
it can't be thanks going up against
Lando because he's at a card table with
a lot of other players it's not like
well it's like well oh he plays a lot of
people clearly but yeah I wanted more
scenes like that I want more traditional
badass kind of cowboys buglar crying
mafia you know more jobless shit I I'm
really kind of shocked it's like the one
cameo I actually legit wanted was job in
this I wanted to see how he met that's
okay they're gonna put him in the
special edition yuen-han to step over
his tail yeah it's like the one time a
lot I actually wanted you to put job in
the launch yeah what if I ever said that
it's like most these movies need less
chopping this is the whole movie where I
got it him in there that is so ironic
cuz even the movie where you first see
Jabba there's too much job I dislike now
third I did like a movie I liked the
Raiders of Lost Ark all the life on that
ground yeah oh yeah they've got like the
Raiders golden head from the beginning
of its arc in the background amongst
what's his face is like trinkets and
stuff
I like me more with Davis - yeah
Warwick Davis you know for people don't
want to split we're probably good we're
mentioning it now this is awesome like
every time I see him is something I'm
like that it seems cool it's the
Leprechaun man I freaking love Warwick
Davis so yeah well as I see morg Davis
like not in the costume yeah I'm like oh
my god it's actually Warwick Davis
they're not like disguising him like
it's not another I guess oh yes yeah is
that so there's these kind of runners
it's a girl plane it's like and they had
a Kim and like the dawn and at first I'm
like oh that like his daughter or
something or says no it's just a girl
and it's like who's why but but but she
had a deep voice with the mascot but but
so what
that made no sense and then just and now
here's the new story now they were
supposed to be saving the people to his
he's big girl and I'm like okay like my
wife said the same thing like this is
like it's because she's a girl it's
because she's literally a girl like she
looks like she's 16 or 17 and I'm like
so is this laughed at that ass is this
like Mad Max is she leading a group of
children I'm like now there's a bunch of
aliens I'm like what what is the
favorite alien children yeah I feel like
I don't um like it's literally like
that's just what they wanted the shock
of like it's a girl like like some kid
and I'm like yeah I I was like what was
the point of it they didn't do they
didn't tell us anything about her except
like yeah we're trying to fight and
here's the other thing it's the exact
same I feel like I just saw the same
movie twice because all of the lines are
echoing last Jenna it's like where the
spark that lights the flame of the fire
for the first resistance and in the
house that ate the mouse at the cat bill
it's just and it's all those same lines
is like odd that the war is just
beginning I'm like well you said that
last Jedi so the war has been beginning
for 40 years another thing so okay so
you got the Empire and they're fighting
the rebellion well okay now we're gonna
go deeper down now there's this really
bad group that like controls people and
they kill people they do terrible things
and a terrible crime but and here's this
other little people that are fighting
them and they want to stop it because of
the terror
but yet that's the empire of the
rebellion while you're creating a
smaller less interesting Empire and a
smart less interesting rebellion like
there's no point once you just make up
the Empire as for whether you you know
what that's the thing it's like I just
wanted crime syndicates and I wanted
like a han Solo
like kind of douche douche bag II like
you know go and talk doing these wings
rhymes yeah claim be like that bit there
yeah and instead they just gave us the
exact same fucking storyline that they
do in a new hope except he just says no
for a while like that's it like yeah not
interested oh I that's fine but like II
this is the exact same crap that
happened in New Hope so we're now seeing
this story twice I don't feel like I
know anything more about Han Solo I
don't know when we get to a new home I
feel like I know more about him from now
last year I uh force awakens ya know in
that way what he's older than I do when
he was younger and that supposed to be
like what's defining him is when he's
younger and if anything it's like why
have it like you should make something
where it's like by the time you get to
New Hope it's like wow he actually came
back to like save Luke and destroy the
Death Star and stuff where it's like
okay already kind of did that before I
took that time why did he need a love
interest anyway like it doesn't inform
his relationship with late I am waiting
for a oh I'm waiting for something major
to like happen with that but it first of
all there's no chemistry with them and
the second nothing made like good
because that tells us something about
because that's from a prequel like when
you do a prequel and you're like okay
we're gonna fill in the rest of that so
it has to help inform you about things
also that happen in you know like
episodes four or five or six or whatever
and like that relationship with her
didn't inform us at all about anything
about his relationship with Leia like I
don't see any damn connection or just
him at all like you know it's like or
having a son in the future or how he's
gonna die or I mean like there's so many
it just it was just it was just the same
storyline but like be a good guy know
and instead of coming back to blow up
the Death Star he just leaves at
the end of this way bet that's it like
it
and again like it's all these nuts like
wink wink guess you're gonna come back
and be a good girl like its duh yeah no
I think that's about it for like all the
big spoiler I did that was weird that
was one great laughs I got though and
they throw in the co axiom or whatever
in the a falcon
alright punch it and they just start
going back and it looks like it's gonna
fall in and then it finally blows up and
and it takes on i I would have paid a
thousand bucks if they got sucked all
the way in and they come out the other
side and they're just like oh we were
scared as thing and pretty much just
dumped us out the other side like but I
thought that's what they were gonna do
with it but I'm like no that probably
would have been like a Lego guys joke
and mildly clever and we're not gonna do
that so I like that shit I did like it
was it was kind of cheating I guess a he
doesn't begin whatever 12 parsecs if you
round down it's an arrogant line yeah
that was a great I did like that there's
a legit good line just like well if you
round down yeah yeah I want to see him
like you know there's the Empire ship
it's like you know okay we gotta get at
me
knock off a TIE fighter or two and then
they're like getting closer we gotta get
out of here we're gonna die we're gonna
die and then they do that trick I was
like no we have to have a squid monster
that goes out really fast and we're
literally just gonna be standing there
for life is another thing that five or
eight minutes and those monsters getting
sucked in they're just second eyes are
some of those eyes open I thought this
is gonna be amazing and it was for like
20 seconds and then it just became like
here's a bunch of tentacles I'm like
yeah it just it didn't really just do
much for me I'm like alright there's a
bunch of tentacles like it's movin I
like it was much more scarier when it
was just those eyes I'm like what the
fuck is that and then it was like no
squid mm-hmm but that was one of the few
flashes of colors at least we got some
orange in there like everything in this
movie was just shot like in shortages
they're offset of around range is like
ground no it's just an ugly ugly movie
and something Star Wars should have his
fucking color
like that's the one thing that you
service is known for no matter what
again in some of those scenes I do want
to be dirty and mucky and brown yeah but
the whole movie slimy I don't know I
don't think if you have a dirty month
when they go to that building where the
head or whatever the vision mafia guy is
that should be colorful that should be
bright that should be amazing that
should be cools very literate to me know
again yeah from the whole what you call
the world war one sequence is just again
it was another excuse to like how do we
suck the color out of this how do we
make this look uninteresting how do we
not show you an exotic location I'm like
what am I gonna you work favorite things
ever in a movie to mask effects or to
just dumb it down to a level where you
don't have to do a bunch of his fog and
rain and this headlight and dirt and Ray
and I'm just like I hate like it's a
galaxy far far away what are we gonna do
a throw in the fog come on don't visit
that that seems okay if the rest of it
looked great and we got the Kessel run
like what are we gonna do yeah that's
throw it in some clouds yeah we got this
we got we got to do this train heist
what are we gonna do throw it in some
mountains and clouds hey we like every
their answers everything was like clouds
yes yes walk it up and it just it's
cheap it came off is so cheap but if
people and they spent so much money on
it well it didn't look like it okay a
lot money I'm sure they did because no
but a lot of you feel it feels cheap and
it shouldn't and a lot of that is just
because they just decided to just shoot
this thing entirely in the fog or in
clouds or with snow and all sorts of
things just covering it up how much so
you don't see the exotic locales I
didn't get that I did the designs were
we're not I got I'll say that the design
seem cheap and recycled and it's like
not the good stuff that's recycled you
know I think too broken and yeah
rogue one head rain rogue one had mud in
certain scenes but was like I still felt
like we were going to exotic locations
at the very end that Imperial base
on the tropical island with the giant
space battle above and the shields is
just like I felt like I saw something
the end of this movie I was like I don't
know what I saw but whatever it was it
was in the Kessel run and some of it was
cool and there was like a giant octopus
in some clouds like though there's
there's like nothing in the finale to
this either like they just fight and
then like vision has like these little
lightsaber knife like things in it it's
just like and I'm just like it's okay
but I'm like this is the lead up fight
into something bigger and there is
nothing it's just like this showdown
then for some lame climax and I'm like
okay yeah maybe if you're making you
know some you know freakin Western or
something but it didn't even feel like
that worthy like oh this is the big
finale like this shootout it's just like
kid yeah I'm gonna there was no
suspenseful you know that one because
I'm still alive nope yeah you know if
Woody Harrelson was like you know almost
like his father
yeah raised him or something like that
that scene would have been like a wall
guess he even says don't make a
connection like okay and they don't but
yeah so that that's the very strange
spoilers of this movement Darth Maul or
then now he's just small cuz I know I'm
sorry
well he's he's only half a second slice
my Darth write off there's gonna be some
phony-baloney bullshit excuse if there
hasn't already who knows maybe this
isn't some spin-off somewhere we haven't
read or seen or watched on Cartoon
Network or a book or something zip up
anymore but yeah so um yeah there it is
weird
Darth Darth Maul lives man that'll be
the next in the next movie I'm sure
Darth Maul with Keira well sir her
name's like Keira and if you watch like
Death Note it's just like a ha was that
a good that's a bad idea remember her no
that's a yeah I thought it was Keira was
I don't remember my next point I
remember who that jon favreau monkey guy
was do rio and i'm just glad he's dead i
did not like that guy at all crumb he
was gonna open a cantina you know
someplace warm but not to our minds
okay can we go over to see you getting
that canteen i don't know what i do want
to talk about that here because this is
a huge problem with the script it
literally feels like a really shitty
1980s like police thriller drama
wherever is like yeah i'm just one week
to retire now everything's working out
now like they literally do that like
yeah it's like four or five times in
this movie i swear okay because it's
star wars but it's like yeah everybody
has that you know it's okay if you can
still make the emotional connector you
have to add something new and just give
them the guy more arms doesn't do that
you really need to make my charm no I
don't care it in turn I'm trying to
think of the Star Wars movie they've
ever done that before like add five
weeks to retirement
yeah those old-school cliches you got a
charm and charisma oh and the other one
where he's just like I got a good
feeling about this I was like cuz you
know this is bad feeling to get it they
switched to them god yeah I met you know
we got to stop because like I was like I
was like really indifferent to this
waiver so but gets a c-plus
yeah it was like this is a C+ movie now
it's like the more I talk about the bomb
like C c-minus d-plus
I have to stop thinking about it and
just be like never think about again
then that way up to spec Amazon alright
so but that's I will just cut out before
you know his thoughts get even meaner
bite we're done we're done but don't lie
do a lie we just did you're right
you